il ya du nouveau dans deux studios et
regardez moi ça au bout de déco ça
change un petit peu bon les choses sont
en train de se mettre à passy dans le
studio
aujourd'hui c'est pas le thème de la
vidéo je vais plutôt vous parler d'une
télé c'est une télé que j'ai depuis
quelques temps et justement je vais me
faire un focus dessus parce que je
trouve vraiment intéressant c'est une
télé philips avec le système ambilight
qui vous permet de retranscrire
l'ambiance que vous avez sur votre
téléviseur direct sur votre mur ça
adapte ce que vous avez sur votre écran
à votre pièce ça à plusieurs intéresse
je vous l'expliqué marc garder là que ça
vous plaît regardez le jeu montrant
plusieurs détails
moi j'ai fait un bout des colosses et
très rock on va trouver des différentes
affiches mais bien je trouvais ça sympa
l'idée d'ailleurs dites moi ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire on à
jimi hendrix les eagles motörhead
nirvana david bowie sex pistols iggy pop
et cannibals téléphone et là je les
cache et style penseurs
[Musique]
ce qui nous intéresse nous aujourd'hui
si tu y six essais la nouvelle télé de
philippe sella série 903 ses modèles 55
pouces avec un écran oled 4k compatible
hd r10 plus alors là je voulais poser là
parce que j'ai pas encore un petit
meuble télé sans quoi je vous l'aurais
lydien coin salon ça aurait été beaucoup
plus sympa ce qui est vraiment
intéressant avec ça c'est pour profiter
du meilleur de la technologie en terme
d'affichage vous avez un écran qui est
magnifique un écran oled 4k 3840 par
2160 pixels vous avez les 139 cm de
diagonale et j'ai besoin d'être la
personne qui fait la météo à la télé 139
cm de diagonale 55 pouces vous avez une
barre de son bowers & wilkins vous
expliquer ça j'ai voulu détailler vous
allez voir truqués est assez
intéressante mais le système qui est
vraiment plus intéressant c'est le
système ambilight c'est à dire le rétro
éclairage précis vous le voyez derrière
là c'est très blanc vous allez pouvoir
tenir le paramétrer ça va venir
s'adapter à votre contenu si vous râlez
quelque chose qui est très rouge très
fun vous élabore un éclairage assez
rouge assez feu derrière chose de très
froid plutôt sur le bleu sur un film
plutôt sur l'océan bien vous aurez toute
une partie plus bleu derrière ça va
vraiment s'adapter on voit ça à 200 s'y
rajoutent vraiment au côté immersif
c'est vraiment le truc intéressant que
surtout ça repose leur il s'est vite la
fatigue oculaire qu'est ce que ça vous
permet d'éclairer une zone derrière
l'idée avec cette terre et c'est
effectivement de profiter du meilleur de
la télé de profiter du système ambilight
d'avoir un système audio de qualité avec
bowers & wilkins ça c'est vraiment
l'idée en tout cas la promesse qui est
fait
excellent écran super son ambilight
lettre-clé rage ambiance dans votre
intérieur sahabi votre intérieur
on va regarder c'est justement philips
tient ses promesses avec cet écran
écouter lors son lancement un peu plus
de 1000 euros là on est un peu moins on
est entre 1500 et 1900 on arrive à
trouver différents puissant loi est
d'ailleurs c'est que intéresse vous avez
des liens en bas dans la description
avec votre téléviseur vous avez deux
télécommandes qui sont fournis première
télécommande c'est une télé quand on le
voit dire un petit peu classique vous
allez pouvoir venir effectivement des
allumés activer le système mobile acquis
et source les paramètres avait pas mal
de choses la navigation gros boutons
netflix si vous utilisez les filles vous
avez d'abonnement ça peut être très très
pratique vous tombera voilà vous le
voyez c'est simple mais ce qui est très
intéressant avec cette télécommande et
ça se passe lorsque vous la retourne est
pas là
et ça vous avez un petit clavier qwerty
alors l'intérêt en fait du clavier
qwerty moi j'ai déjà dit tout de suite
lorsque j'ai voulu rentrer mon mot de
passe wi fi et croyez moi c'est beaucoup
plus pratique de naviguer avec ça que de
s'embêter avec les flèches valider tout
ça vraiment vraiment vraiment beaucoup
plus pratique vous pourrez probablement
trouver d'autres intérêts si vous
rentrez notamment votre mot de passe
netflix moi je l'avais directement
enregistrées avec mon compte google donc
ça c'était plutôt cool et vous avez une
deuxième télécommande celle là est un
peu plus sommaire elle vous servira pour
parler à google assistant avec un petit
micro pour commander votre android tv
accusée de faire l'objet est plutôt
sympa raconte à un peu je dirais un côté
un peu ancienne génération avec une
télécommande un peu plus classique une
télécommande un peu plus design un peu
plus d'écho mais en tout cas les deux
fonctionnent la première chose c'est les
reflets là je les ai effectivement mis
avec le gros panneaux led qui est située
la boule voyez donc c'est à dire
vraiment ce réfléchir c'est assez fort
mais si vous n'avez pas de panneaux led
comme ça chez vous un sinon c'est que
vous aimez vous faire monsieur et vous
voulez vraiment tout éclairé très fort à
côté de ça vous avez la fenêtre que vous
voyez qui est ici donc on a quand même
du reflet le reflet quand même atténuée
lorsque vous la mettez la en mode veille
lorsque vous arrivez là le reflet quand
même atténuée vous l'avez néanmoins je
vous conseille quand même ne pas la
mettre avec une baie vitrée derrière en
règle générale c'est parfait pour il ya
des télés qui maîtrise parfaitement bien
le système de reflets s'est atténuée
mais c'est pas extrêmement parfait le
poids qui bouge kcc les angles de vision
n'a des angles de vision qui sont assez
bien ce qui fait que lorsque vous mettez
vraiment sur le côté que tout le monde
et pas face à la télé et bien vous
perdez pas en qualité
vous êtes sur un android tv android tv7
nougat on n'est pas sur la dernière
version d'android tv néanmoins ça
fonctionne vous retrouvez donc la base
votre google assistant qui situent juste
là vous avez vos différentes
applications de l'extrême vidéo rakuten
youtube que vous voulez le googleplex
vous pouvez venir personnalisé mais ce
que vous voulez netflix bien évidemment
où là je vais avoir pas tous mes films
et séries pour ça vous y connaissez ça
marche youtube ça c'est vrai ce que je
regarde je regarde des tornades et puis
je regarde and style pourquoi pas vous
allez vous retrouver avec play in thé
vert fin des séries des films à louer
vous allez pouvoir personnaliser votre
écran d'accueil c'est vraiment un
android tv un pur et dur ça marche bien
l'expérience est cool vous la
personnaliser comme vous voulez vous en
faites ce que vous voulez un des points
forts c'est la partie audio bowers &
wilkins vous avez ici une barre de son
qui se planquent ici d'ailleurs ses
marques et la up
bowers & wilkins vous avez donc tout de
suite parti barre de son qe planqué ici
mais si vous venez regarder par derrière
vous avez également une partie audio qui
a intégré à l'arrière et ce qui est
sympa à l'aria c'est que vous retrouvez
vraiment le système ambilight des trois
côtés c'est à dire sur le côté là donc
vous permettre d'éclairer le côté de
votre mur le au tac tac tac tac est
également de l'autre côté c'est pas si
vous le voyez vous voyez vous avez les
led qui sont planqués de ce côté-là
aussi nager couper les lumières se
couper les éclairages de face a juste la
lumière naturelle du jour la télé qui
est là on a du rouge là ça vous
retranscris du rouge
ici ça vient vraiment changer en
fonction de ce que je le regardais la
toux le jeune derrière ça change
vraiment et ça c'est vraiment vraiment
intéressante pour moi c'est vraiment
l'élément essentiel la qualité de
l'écran est vraiment là vous avez un
truc qui est vraiment top super qualité
les contrastes sont top les noirs sont
infinies les couleurs sont vraiment très
très très bonne vous avez une dalle qui
est super band bien maîtrisée de la
partie phillips fille a aucun problème
ça marche parfaitement bien mais le fait
de pouvoir ajouter tout ce système
ambilight derrière c'est là où ça va
vraiment créer l'intérêt de ce produit
s'adapte aux puces à la couleur de votre
fond derrière moi j'ai un mur blanc et
ça marche très très bien mais si vous
avez parlé une belle tapisserie prunes
pourquoi pas petit papy mamie ou alors
si vous faites comme fait valérie
damidot des murs toutes les couleurs à
bien à ce moment-là s'adaptera aux la
couleur de votre mur derrière et je vous
dis c'est pour moi le truc vraiment le
plus pertinent sur cette télé c'est ce
système ambilight la partie audio est
bien mais on pourrait s'attendre à
quelque chose d'un peu mieux après c'est
souvent le problème de ces télés si vous
voulez un peu tout en un avec une barre
de son intégrée on peut pas avoir le top
de la qualité le meilleur de la qualité
partout si vous voulez profiter vraiment
d'une meilleure expérience audio mieux
vaut prendre une barre de son à part
avec carrément un caisson de basses vous
voulez vraiment que ça ronronne la
l'audio est pas mal les médiums sont
assez précis mais ds vous voulez être
plus dans le graphe ci vous pouvez plus
grave s'ils voulaient que ça ronronne
ben là tu sais la parole et après ça
fait tâche vous avez de tweeter à dôme
de titane vous avez deux haut parleurs
médium d'iwate et vous avez un haut
parleur grave de 30 watts ça fait la
faire mais c'est vrai que si vous êtes
sur un film d'action comment vous voulez
que ça ronronne du petit peu voilà aussi
d'être un petit peu limité là dessus
maintenant y'a un truc qui est vraiment
bien vous allez le processeur philips p5
qui marche très très bien le traitement
d'image est parfaitement bien maîtrisée
de la partie lips et en plus ce qui
marche bien c'est l'umps kelly il ya
beaucoup de contenu vous allez pouvoir
retrouver qui ne sont pas en quatre
canettes
qui sont en full hd et vous avez un
travail d'homme styling thalys à prendre
notre contenu en full hd
ça va le payer ça va le monter en
qualité pour que vous puissiez l'affiché
sur un écran 4 cas en ayant de la
qualité 4k et c'est vrai ça marche
vachement bien moi par exemple les
vidéos sont diffusées en faut lâcher
regarde là dessus lorsque la qualité est
vraiment top ici que vous êtes sur un
android tv donc vous avez google
assistante vous pouvez tous venir
piloter rien qu'à la voix il ment des
maîtres le programme que vous souhaitez
vous pouvez aussi régler vos lumières
alors si vous avez un système avec
philips ou c'est merveilleux pour lui
demander de monter ou baisser le
thermostat enfin vous pilotez votre
maison connectée directement votre
google assistant depuis votre téléviseur
vous avez en plus chrome 4 ne gâche pas
le plaisir vous avez le plextor je vais
vous avez vos films vous avez d'être
flic zeppelin d'application de tous les
côtés donc ça ça va c'est bien pour
avoir une bonne expérience
android tv la typiquement vous être
qu'en est il maintenant au niveau de la
connectique alors regardez vous avez un
petit peu ce qu'il faut vous avez deux
usb vous avez plein de port vous avez du
hdmi un peu de tous les côtés et en
dessous vous est ce qu'il faut si vous
avez une sortie optique vous avez une
prise rj45 grippe ce qu'il faut pour
votre sac tu lis votre antenne vous êtes
tranquille et vous rajoutez même encore
de hdl ici alors ça c'est assez sympa
maintenant il ya tout ce que j'ai
vraiment bien regretter ici c'est
dommage que le philips n'est pas amis
c'est qu'en fait vous avez rien pour le
passage de câbles
vous avez vos câbles qui sont là qui
sont là qui vont venir pendouiller vous
allez faire pendouiller dessous alors si
s'est posée comme ça comme c'est très
très faim si vous voulez et bien à nice
à être un petit peu discret pour les
attacher avec un élastique mais c'est
vrai que ces trucs un petit peu dommage
parce que il aurait fallu un petit
passage de câbles qui arrivent au centre
d'une petite boulotte facile tous passés
entre seul et même endroit là ça aurait
été bien
ici il n'y a absolument rien voilà ça je
trouve que pour moi c'est vraiment un
point de regrets il aurait pu aller
beaucoup plus loin en terme de finition
ici et là c'est pas le cas par contre la
finition globale sur le téléviseur à la
vente sont vraiment irréprochable
jeannie est ce que vous avez toute la
partie écran sur le dessus la partie bar
2 sont en bas et des pieds qui sont
extrêmement fin on a ce côté un petit
peu tissu qui donne un côté très déco
très actuel on a un léger cadre léger
cadre je sais pas si c'est en en alu que
vous avez sur le côté qui va faire tout
le tour
qui est vraiment très très profilé très
joli ça c'est super élégant un tout
petit bord l'envoyer au niveau de votre
écran c'est extrêmement fins vous
arrivez directement sur l'écran
donc on a quelque chose qui est très
élégant qui est très jolie qui
s'intègrent parfaitement bien dans un
intérieur là vous avez le branding
phillips sur ce biais là et l'autre côté
vous avez le branding au niveau de
l'audio bowers wilkins
donc ça c'est sympa une télé qui est
très bien réussi de la part de philippe
d'un poilu
purement esthétiques comme ça lorsque
vous la poser sur 20 alors effectivement
sur cette petite table là c'est pas
terrible sur un joli meuble télé c'est
très très très bien très joli en plus
c'est très facile à installer parce que
vous avez des petits pieds la ccid de
vis de chaque côté ce stade très
rapidement très facile on se prend pas
la tête mais on peut peut-être lui
reprocher un peu de latence lorsque vous
allez venir jouer à des jeux ça se
mesure en millisecondes ça va dépendre
des jeux sur certains jeux ça pourrait
potentiellement poser problème dans
notre absolument pas c'est un point de
détail
à côté de ça l'expérience globale moi je
trouve bien joli l'écran de qualité
lo'jo et bien le système ambilight est
vraiment vraiment vraiment top ça
devrait être sur tous les téléviseurs le
système ambilight personnellement
j'adore je suis vraiment très très fan
ce que c'est vraiment super marqué sur
un gros amoureux du système philips ue
et pour venir complètement décorer votre
maison avec de l'éclairage sage pour ça
vraiment bien le faire vous puissiez
vous le rapportez sur votre télévision
après qu'ils aient souvent l'élément
central dans un salon c'est souvent le
cas donc le fait de pouvoir l'intégrer
comme ça sur un produit qui est joli
quai des coq et design pour moi ça
marche puisque envie d'habiter un des
points essentiels je vous montrais garde
héros c'est un petit clic on va sur les
paramètres on va dans mon village on
peut arrêter ambilight s'ils voulaient
absolument pas lumière sinon vous avez
suivre vidéo suivre audio suivre couleur
vous mettez de la musique ça va suivre
votre musique donc ça veut dire bouger
la musique va changer en fonction du
rythme de la musique suivre couleurs
suivre drapeau bleu-blanc-rouge sais pas
si vous le voyez bien comme ça ici après
peut même avoir sur différentes
applications suivre couleur je coupe
éclairage que vous puissiez vous en
rendre compte
l'aja côté qui est légèrement vers parce
que j'ai dû vérifier j'ai un côté un peu
plus rouge parce que j'ai vu rouge ici
ça c'est toujours très très cool et là
vous avez standard naturel football vif
s'appelle vaches n'ont pu déposer sur le
vif
je confort détente c'est beaucoup plus
dur va se mettre sur le vif ça nous
permettra de faire ressortir davantage
ses lumières la sainte baume vachement
bien on a vraiment des couleurs qui sont
complètement adaptative par rapport à ce
que vous allez retrouver et les côtés un
petit peu bleus le côté un peu plus au
rouge beaucoup plus chaleureux ici
hop on va récupérer voyez le orange ici
et ça fait vraiment vraiment apporter ma
chance a vraiment vraiment vraiment cool
ça apporte vraiment de l'animation et
hop fond de retour au studio pour les
hommes sur un écran qui est vraiment
excellent pour tous les amoureux je
dirais delà des coûts qui veulent
vraiment une télé décoratives qui est
très belle s'intègrent bien
à l'intérieur on peut venir
personnaliser sa lumière avec le système
ambilight c'est vraiment le point fort
de ce modèle de cette télé là si vous
voulez une très belle qualité d'image là
dessus vous êtes tranquille si vous
voyez ce qui se fait de mieux en terme
d'audience
c'est pas forcément ce qu'il sait que ça
marche très très bien mais vous manquez
un petit peu de voyez un peu de grave ça
ronronne pas nommément
ça peut être un peu le point négatif
qu'on s'est vraiment ce mandat de
prendre un système extérieur si vous
voulez profiter d'une excellente qualité
audio
néanmoins ça marche quand même pas mal
on va pas cracher dans la soupe il ya ce
système de passage de cap qui est pas
terrible terrible si l épouse est comme
ça ça va mais si vous voulez suspendre
votre télé tout de suite c'est pas
terrible c'est pas très joli ça ça
demanderait être revue et améliorée de
la part de philips le fait qu'ils aient
un peu de latence et pas forcément
problématique si vous n'êtes pas un
gamer a déterré si vous jouez pas
énormément que sur noté avec votre
android télé normalement ça va quand
même plutôt bien se passer si vous êtes
façon un gamer j'imagine que vous avez
soit en or 10 soit une console autre
chose qu'on pouvait jouer dont bon ça
devrait quand même relativement calmes
moi je trouve plutôt bien je trouve
intéressante et en plus ce qui est
vraiment bien c'est qu'en termes de prix
je vous dis elle a chuté par rapport à
ce que vous la trouviez il ya quelques
mois j'ai mis les liens en bas d'un
description entre mille 4005 jusqu'à
mille neuf mois ce que vous en pensez
comment vous la trouvez que cette télé
cette proposition 7 55 pouces oled série
903 de philips et surtout le système
ambilight comment vous trouvez est-ce
qu'il vous intéresse vous voyez un
intérêt est ce que vous pourriez vous
l'achetez marque il m'a tout ça en va et
dites moi si ça vous intéresse
on reparle de téléviseurs parler du deux
télés de lg on a parlé de samsung on
parle aujourd'hui de philips et on peut
envisager d'en parler encore donc dites
moi ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
dès demain vous embrasse tous